Звичайний ранок звичайної
жінки-військовослужбовця української армії.
32-річна офіцер-психолог Світлана Ковбасюк
виконує спочатку материнські обов’язки,
а потім вже військові.
В армії ці обов’язки і для жінок, і для чоловіків однакові.
Однакова навіть форма. І вона - чоловіча.
Натільна білизна, скажімо так, чоловічого зразка.
Ви розумієте, що тут потрібно
убрати, і було б непогано.
Такі кальсони жінкам дозволено не носити.
І це єдиний виняток.
Решта форми є обов’язковою і її доводиться
перешивати, адже чоловіча одежа не враховує
особливостей жіночої фігури. А деякі деталі форми
взагалі не можна змінити.
Для груді тут якби немає, не виготовлено нічого,
але можна носити.
Вона пряменька така собі йде, якби.
За кілька років служби за контрактом Світлана
вже навчилася і у чоловічій формі виглядати жіночо.
Адже, каже психолог, головне - не форма , а зміст.
Жінкам в армії вже дозволено робити різні зачіски,
макіяж, навіть носити прикраси.
Головне, щоб все було охайно і не заважало.
Українська армія в жіночому питанні намагається
впроваджувати стандарти НАТО.
Прес-служба Генштабу ЗСУ запевняє, що за
три останні рокибагато зроблено для зміни
нормативних документів з урахуванням потреб жінок.
Зокрема, розробляють дизайн жіночої форми,
а також стандарти жіночого взуття, аби жінки не
були змушені, як деякі з цих курсанток, носити
берці на два-три розміри більші.
Немає маленьких розмірів з 35-ого,
не з 37-ого, з 35-ого.
Жінки росту метр п’ятдесят два
мають проблеми, авони в армії є.
І проблем цих багато не лише з амуніцією,
а ще і з побутом.
Поки не в кожному підрозділі є окремі жіночі
казарми, душові, медичні палати.
Не всі командири-чоловіки взагалі можуть зрозуміти,
як вирішувати труднощі, з якими жінки стикаються в армії.
ЗСУ має пришвидшити процес виконання стандартів
гендерної рівності та збільшити кількість жінок-командирів.
Світлана, приміром, за доволі короткий термін,
2 роки, змогла вирости з інструкторки
до заступниці командира роти.
Але таким успіхам жінок в ЗСУ раді далеко не всі.
В деяких випадках є, щочоловіки не дуже
сприймають жінку, як військовослужбовця.
Вони хочуть показати, що жінка повинна бути вдома.
Я своїм прикладом показую, що ні…
Ми теж можемо, ми теж на рівних правах.
Гендерна реформа в українській армії,
відповідно до різних програм ЗСУ,
триватиме не один рік.
Світлана вважає, що жінкам-військовослужбовцям
слід ініціювати створення такої собі жіночої ради,
яка б могла теж брати участь
в обговоренні гендерних змін.
Адже нині в армії служать близько 24 тисяч жінок.
Це на 8 тисяч більше, ніж ще три роки тому.